chair I've got the ability if you wish
to bring anything up on the screen
that's a screen for members we don't
necessarily have to share in the life VP
but if you don't want to but I can share
my screen at any point to put up the
agenda or any the paperwork if you if
you want to refer to an it so if you
just ask at any point I will just do it
for you right thanks des it again an old
thing so today today's gonna be the
first of the new year one or two new
members
you
enough allocate tech support call you
straight back and get you back online if
at any point the live feed goes down I
will have to very gently and just excuse
you from the meeting and just apologize
to you
you
you
you
you afternoon welcome counselors to this
meeting of the gross scrutiny committee
this is a public meeting being streamed
live to YouTube and via the council's
website I have been advised that the
livestream is now up and running if you
for any reason that the public can no
longer hear or see the meeting over the
livestream we will adjourn until the
connection has been re-established I
will ask the governance manager to
confirm who is in attendance to explain
the procedure for this meeting I should
have to turn the microphone on as well
Nicola apology's chair could you just
hold the line just one moment I'm just
going to check back on a technical issue
okay
apologies fetcher I have confirmation
that we actually live streaming we had a
completion there whether it was actually
working in properly so thank you chair
just to advise members that microphones
should remain muted at all times during
the meeting unless of course if you've
been called on to speak by the pair this
is to minimize the background noise
members can leave their cameras on
during the meeting if they feel that in
doing so it enhances the debate if any
memories indicate this by a muting a
microphone and raising a hand you may
also use the chat function and type
speak the chair will then call on you to
speak as appropriate voting will be done
so by acclamation hands will indicate
that the committee is in agreement any
time how disconnected from the meeting
please try to rejoin as quickly as
possible if you have any technical
difficulties please contact one of the
meeting facilitators as indicated on the
meeting access details if you are about
to speak the meeting will wait a few
moments for you to rejoin Thank You
chair ok moving on apologies for absence
can the doones manager please advise if
there have been any apologies for
absence Thank You councillor Pat and
cliff has sent apologies for this
meeting right thank you very much are
there any more apologies councilors wish
to submit the apologies on behalf of an
absent member please Tony my firm's on
anybody apologies for anybody else
right thank you that's been noted if any
members do have any interested Eclair
can you please turn the cameras on now
these microphones on now
no interest right thank you for that
item three minutes of last meeting can
we agree that the minutes of the last
meeting were a true and accurate record
they're really really were to knock your
record
but excellent thank you for that right
item for remit of the committee
can I please introduce Subin to the
meeting plate
Thank You chair also I'm Silberman I'm
the of you in Silesia managed to this
committee I just wanted to provide the
new committee we could reminder the key
points of what scrutineers
what it can do in your pack you will see
that you have a terms of reference sheet
that provides details of what is in
within the committee's remit it also
shows on the other committee limits are
as I'm sure but members will be on this
committee for a while we'll know that
sometimes items can cut across to
committees and the chairs they need to
come to a decision whether they will
undertake that work one example of this
is housing where housing management sits
within the community disputing committee
but how this Ashley sits within this
committee additionally if you have an
item you wish to raise which is not in
your committee tournament
you can raise this with a relevant chair
of the committee in which it sits and so
they can consider whether they wish to
take that into their committee and if
you wish to do that with any item I can
facilitate time so some key points of
scrutiny scoot is mechanism to backbone
counselors to monitor council prominence
there's a number of ways you can do this
including that you can use performance
information we can monitor action plans
from various places and you can be alert
to service performance on the ground
where perhaps the services not forming
as as you like it or there's been an
issue that's been brought to your
attention you can also examine cabinet
holds ons and decisions for each meeting
you will see on the agenda that you
already have before plan of executive
decisions and we look at this every time
to allow the committee to oversees these
decisions and you can raise issues for
the press for the information about
subjects on that another method you can
use is it you can country
to policymaking you can do this by being
involved to the console key and that
should happen automatically as a school
committee
you should be consulted on anything that
comes within you leave it or you can
monitor how long are see work in and if
you're out something that you wish to
take forward you can make
recommendations for improvement to the
cabinet you can also review issues of
concern
say something promote students on behalf
of the communities however scrutiny
cannot make decisions or policies it
does however have the power of influence
it can make informed recommendations to
cabinets or to baggage evidence which is
gathered from a mix of stakeholders
including offices partners and the
public and the members who've been on
this committee for a while you'll know
how it operates but for the new members
and it has two main aspects usually the
first one is that you usually sign on an
annual work program on the agenda item
six you will have a chance to decide
what items you would like to look at
during the year items tend to be things
that are contained in one meeting and
are mainly chosen because they support
and add value to the priorities of the
council and help improve the service it
delivers the committee also has a role
in listening to concerns raised by
elected members and public and I need to
just say maybe the work program is not a
a set document it's a work in progress
and it needs to have a mix of activity
with room to spare so if any emerging
issues come up or any urgent items the
committee's asked consider you can
respond to them vegetative of the
program when thinking about your work
program it's important to consider what
you can influence and what values your
choice for quality your closest lat
the second area of work that committee
museum detects it's the selection of a
topical Scruton review this is normally
done in most cases by an in-depth review
that last for the entire municipal
career year period
that is a committees meeting because
it's a significant piece of work
however alternatively you can also use
the spot marketing method to do very
quick reviews but these are generally
more straightforward topics that need a
quick response because the quiet
intensive however given the situation
we're in at the moment through the
pandemic that may be an option that you
may wish to consider is Republic way to
do review work a tenth item five on the
agenda the chair will invite me to
discuss and put forward any possible
topics for consideration for your
reviewing topic I did actually send out
a form with the agenda the members to
put down any items that they might be
interested in and also how to talk
couples from offices so we can talk
about that when we start and then just
for information J I could just run
through the key stages of an in-depth
view so topic is selected after
discussion by the committee and the
proposer of why the Union should be
undertaken and what how can you hope to
achieve the bureau is then sculpt
informally by the chair and vice chair
the lead occifer the service that is
connected to the Libyan the overview and
scrutiny manager and if appropriate the
person that just proposed the review
that has been selected honoring lists
immobile meeting the timetable and
project plan which is essentially in
your stockin document is prepared and
will be brought back to the committee so
that the committee can then further
discuss and reach agreement that it's
what you're hoping to to look at the
only in scattering then begins through
interviews with stakeholders possible
site visits review of documentation like
pauses
action plans and performance information
but in fact it could be anything that
the committee thinks is relevant to the
issue that we're looking at at the end
of the year you analyze all the other
heard and formulate them terminations to
be included inscription for
this is then submitted to cabinet the
pastor devaluation
if cabinet assess the recommendations a
lead officer prepares an action plan on
behalf of cabinet which are committing
them monitor through the year to ensure
that the recommendations are implemented
and that's really I have to say chair
that you have to conclude if the
committee have any questions on that do
you think or anything else new scrutiny
you have to take Thanks looks like
there's no questions ever it seems quite
happy with that I wish more - thanks
again super item 5 and first of all I
forgot - so I mentioned we've got a
couple of new members from last year and
I don't know whether we've lost anybody
do you think for the the point of view -
of the the public we just feel round
everybody and just introduce everybody
you
so is it worth useful when we use pillow
okay I mean because we're all looking at
each other in a different order on the
screen shall I just call the names out
and you just say who you are you mind
doing that um so Suzy
are you there Suzy you mind just
introducing yourself you until you might
film oh hi my name's Suzie I'm
councillor for Heath and Homewood Duke
yes for that thank you
and counsel at the Gosforth belly gong
field Thank You counselor John for now
hi I'm Jonathan Allen counselor for
pihl's Lee Morton instructing Thank You
counselor Michelle Evans well and
counselor Emmons for Gosford valet and
drum filled thank you what's the Nigel
Barker morning oh good afternoon even
when I'm out where am i how counselor
good afternoon I'm counselor Nikki
Whitehead for Killam ash
this is my second year on the scrutiny
committee go scrutiny committee I'm
looking forward to getting stuck into
some of the areas that clearly are going
to need some some support as we come out
this virus situation come on thank you
for that Lee
get canceled out Sean from gas more and
whimsicott Thank You Julian is sorry and
it's there can you hear me I can hear
you I can't see you to be honest but I
can hear you
and now I can't you turn your microphone
off
oh you're to interview so loudly
petanque cliff can you hear me yes we
can hear you fine farm house can't see
you but aunt clue said winkworth
canceled it's all I have to say thank
you very much and I'm counselor Anthony
Hutchinson I represent John field
colostrum John field and right mr.
dissection mmm I think we we should be
discussing what we are going to look at
I think he's some of it's going to be
quite self selecting because the
situation we're in Keene we we had like
the Year last year with a lot of new
members and we didn't choose a review
I'm keen that we proactively Shakira and
we choose review and and I'd like to
invite anybody to suggest any and he
reviews early part of the council's work
you'd like to look at everybody
counselor I Ted hello yeah thanks
something I'm not sure whether this
should be a spotlight review or perhaps
the main review but I noticed in 2018-19
looking at the summary of what the
committee did it included the
homelessness I'm part of the council and
I've been reading through that it
contained nine recommendations that I'd
be interested to know if we've if we've
made progress on those recommendations
and where they ended up but furthermore
going into this year as we see from our
meetings that that the and the
corresponding from the leader in that
the homelessness are obviously had a big
change and what's happened to their
environment and and this is a moment in
time where we can really grasp this and
I hope as a council we do so I would
like to ensure that this committee you
know does review that element of
what the council is doing I take
personal interest in out got some
knowledge and background with it so so
it's a personal interest of mine whether
it warrants a full review or a spotlight
right thank you thanks for that soon
just a note sure your Mike Tobin you
wanted to say some things I can't see I
mean I've been quite shocked to hear
that that word re may be part of
something that we can discuss that would
be the community's remit not not gross
as soon to be a man what would that be
something that wouldn't because of
communities rather than ours Thank You
Chad I was just yes I was just going to
come in on that March it was a review
that was undertaken by the communities
committee it is still live and Hector
was due to come back and report progress
on it's been quite a bit of progress
name but unfortunately with the pandemic
and that last me eating of the Queen's
kitty being canceled it didn't come to
that but it will be certainly coming
back in the new word problem that it is
actually out of the remit of this
committee yes sorry my mistake
yes however kind of all however chair
can I also just say in the past the
committees have been very cooperative
and if a member has a particular
interest in a subject matter with
agreement to the chair of the
appropriate committee and often they
allow you to sit in and obviously listen
to the debates on that issue
I think you should be very interested in
being invited to those conversations as
well if that's possible
okay why thank you for that anybody else
got any suggestions you did Shirley John
John Paul yeah Anthony we we spent most
of last year waiting for the growth
strategy to come out of the district
council and there is circumstances
reasoning we never actually got the
growth strategy that we could look at so
we would wait a little bit for that to
come out but I do now now that the
district of the point is a new director
for growth there will be a different
game plan now I guess with Kovac coming
up but can we invite the new director to
come on to our meeting to explain what
the girls strategy is for the future I
think that's something that could do is
listen to Valen chair and that I noticed
that Joe Carr Gomm is actually on the
screen for this you can actually hear
the meeting
I be in the meeting be with us ah hello
yes it's my first media lab yes I'm
happy to bring the bro strategy when two
informal cabinet the angry so we're
doing some changes to it now to line up
with Co good 19 and what's coming out of
that so happy to bring back to to be
reviewed that's what you'd like
okay and just on the harmlessness I
don't know if the reason its it was
raised is that homelessness now comes
unto me and in a stretch of ground so
I'm not sure where it would then sit
going forward it's like right okay thank
gives that nigel you are you're just
going to just join in there yes yeah I
think that that that's useful and like
you say I think the the code word things
throw on a different different angle on
on stuff and I know Julie again it's a
bit referring to you because I'm kinda
that we we add value to stuff as a
student committee and now it's nice to
to look at decisions that have been made
and and an old people to account but I
find it's it's more rewarding to
actually look forward as where we where
we can add value and improve things and
and and a know on our side obviously
homelessness is one issue well I think
that's another committee I think for us
I'm just looking at the list where
you've got tourism partnerships planning
and all that sort of stuff and I know
you'll you'll send a thing out asking
for really things in the district that
we can we can sell if you lie we've in
our area are the three of us really we
bought the fire pits trail we've got all
the country part you know the gas more
country part and and they are really
popular and I'd like to law and it does
be muted or not my if Lea that that we
need some joined up working with that
regarding the County Council the the
countryside services and you know
national heritage and all that sort of
stuff so I'd like to do a project and I
know there might be more important
things but I think it's summer that this
committee could really add value to our
do improve tourism in Northeast abbis
you and come up with some ideas that's
that's where I saw to be coming from if
that makes any sense
yeah that does make sense your honor
thank you
yeah it's sorry Susie can i stir the
subir money son absolutely because I
can't see yes I don't know everything
you wanted when an earlier soon Oh Susie
Susie please come back in service
homelessness is now coming under the
growth agenda and we can bring that into
our discussion along with Nick I would
absolutely love to discuss that and but
following on from Nigel I mean during
the during leader the lockdown
the five pits bail has been an absolute
jewel in our crown and it saved my son
and I cannot tell you and so if we I do
want to discuss tourism the growth
committee about I've never come off it
I've been on it for about three years
and we have discussed tourism but I
think if we've got a new director and a
new thought process that I would very
much be keen to talk about tourism and
all the things that we can promote and
within our own our district okay so I
just want to add that right thanks cuz
yeah now that I'm with you on that
tourism something I'm I'm really quite
quite keen on myself superman' Thank You
chair just a couple of things to come
back come on Judith sagged and
homelessness of cost isn't in Jill's
remit now it isn't actually in terms of
the remit of the committee that way at
the Melbourne but of course if that's
something that what you want to change
to mirror the new directors role that's
certainly something I'm sure soesterberg
about and get sorted because I know
she's been looking at whether we need to
do any amendments around the mix of the
communities obviously one or two things
I've changed in terms of the tourism
issue something that
a couple of times on this committee
quite a while ago now so it might be
useful to left to go back to that and I
just mentioned two other things chair
and the leader also I asked three new
offices and the new cabinet about
whether they had any things he wanted to
put into the committee for consideration
and the leader had said yes did anything
around the local economy would be good
obviously for him the panic and one of
the heads of service call apps but put
in place a proper way after the pandemic
you
yeah I think of I'm you to put yourself
off to oh are you finished
you
you know thank you well we got one or
two stronger shiny it's around I just
thought and people be keen sorry sorry
leak can I just bring you in
yeah it was just a little bit more on
the tourism side really it's just
finished chatting I think the other
aspect is we've got the a61 coroner
there's not been linked through to the
five bits trail
basically finishes at store third lane
which and with the AC the national cycle
route 67 which runs through right
through to Killa mass which joins up
both are our areas but we've got to also
work with Chesterfield borough and all
the council's on that probably bowls
over 12 to develop a plan for the OL
area really rather than just it just
being northeast are be sure well it
could link both sides of our of our
district talk basically and I think
that'd be quite a good thing to do which
also includes the Avenue site which is
obviously still being developed and I
think that'd be a good way forward
yeah thank thanks Lee yes I'll bring you
in please
yeah thanks Anthony and just from the
last year that we've just done we did
find it very difficult to make progress
on growth scrutiny not out of lack of
will it just felt that we were trying to
actually create policy and I think what
we need to do is scrutinize so when we
talk about these things that we want to
do um to help me get over the line and
hopefully everyone is that we need when
we talk about growth in any aspect what
are we going to scrutinize what's the
document what is the process what is the
cabinet member what is that who are the
people we need to nail that bit first
because I felt I felt like we drifted
last year we hadn't we were try and
basically coming up with with opinions
and policies and that's not scrutiny so
hopefully if you've been on obviously
the committee is it a good technique of
doing that and you just feel that we do
need some kind of document or something
to scrutinize rather than just going off
on a tangent of a lot of opinions and
ideas yeah I think that's what John was
was trained really we hadn't gone and we
aren't gobbled Eric just sort of going
around around trying to bit of this talk
about a bit of that but we can't carry
on like that we've got to pick up on
something and I think today as as we
come out to it well eventually we're
going to come out of this this pandemic
and things are changing and the going
back to leading courage cycling for
example and gain out and and I think
that's the new future and I think that I
think that's a much better subject to be
looking at because that's you know it's
better followed isn't it
surveyman please
- oh no that's just going to add to that
giant I understand counsel whiteheads
frustration as you remember the chair
the previous chair took the decision
that she felt there were lots of areas
that maybe the council's didn't know
about this new committee with new
members - on the council's so the spent
quite a lot of time looking about
various things whereas usually you would
be doing a piece of a new work and that
will blade and you main piece of
scrutiny and of course the Grouse
scratching its strategies RP document
which we didn't have and the new one
obviously we'd have the old one which
was scrutinizing you before but
obviously that's a key document there's
a pattern and screws nice yeah right
yeah okay thank you it wasn't a
criticism of the the previous chair
chair and chairwoman and it was just you
were all quite new and we just need to
be so go around the house a little bit
counsel Nigel bark okay thank you
so can I just a bit of clarity on on
what the cabinet and Oh Martin said I
can understand this because it is
alluded to it in his in his daily
briefings and and another thing that the
current economic recovery is going to be
massive going forward I just wondered
what part could we play in that as a as
a scrutiny committee I'm a bit it sounds
a bit of a big project that does I don't
know have you any thoughts on that
Stu ube Mount Saint Suleiman pursuit so
I don't confuse you a suti call so then
please thank you Joe yes I don't have
any more detail on the chair and I think
it was probably a conversation that
would need to be had if that is what you
wanted to pursue but of course the
economy covers a vast majority of
different subjects as you said and that
would be too much to take
but of course tourism can form part of
the debate around the economy so that
could be something come on that theme
that you might want to look at you've
suggested I don't know if they do has
any say on that as you're growing
thoughts on that one
what would the would the tourism sort to
link into that it requests you know we
need to have to project two options
Jim are you there you I am here yeah
sorry I'm trying to I'm trying to think
it through the real win the great
strategy that we're reviewing it but
that comes with a recovery plan about
what what our priorities are in order to
get the economy going of the next
initially up to 18 months and then past
that so there's one piece of work there
there's a greater strategy itself and
that's a strategy documents it doesn't
go into masses of detail although there
will be a a action plan with it as part
of the growth strategy the tourism
strategy just link into that because
that's an area that we rode the economy
through and that and that's really the
sort of the thread that goes through
them all it is incredibly complicated
and I'm running my foot this fourth week
so I'm still trying to work out the
areas there may be some areas that
actually might be really helpful to get
you know get some ideas on but I can't
tell you exactly what they are at the
moment right Thank You Jill thank you
Margie yeah just just stop back to that
and I we pressured into actually making
the decision today given the state of
where we are with with the economic
recovery and all that sort of stuff
it goes back to I said I don't mind
doing and giving time up to this if I
feel there's a bit la what Nick said it
you could go around in circles and you
don't one another but nothing happens
and I think we should try and at least
ever of what is our goal what are we
trying to do while we trying to improve
services what you know improve the
economy what sorry MIT and really have a
focus down on and another an end product
really that's and I'm not sure I'm
quietly a yet in my head how we're going
to deal with that
I don't think we are already an
impression today in agile at all but I'm
just keen after the last year that we
sort of travel forward a little bit sue
Airmen so
hello sue I was going to say thank you
the same thing
Joe about it's up to the committee you
choose your review and you take your
time if you want to go if you want to
have a couple of subjects and you want
to go back to the lead officers and add
some further information where you might
be accustomed going to that you can do
that and then bring that back to the
next meeting
thank you sue as we thank you as we
really so discussing divorce for any
city so James
but is this in some way where we can as
we go away
you
between the committee then at your next
formal committee then beside on that or
even you can miss that middle stage out
and not have that you can just read the
comments due to me or FINA back to the
chair and then we can reach agreement by
email to then giving to be approved for
the next meeting so what does everybody
think of that
just trying to get moving [ __ ] Nick
yeah yeah thanks actually I think we
need to we don't need to decide today
for sure like Nigel saying but we're in
we're obviously making the edge of just
floating so I think we need to normally
you have a proposed in a second we do a
vote we don't need to do that type of
thing they just sound like going forward
the key thing for our area probably
every area in the country will be this
recovery and growth so we spoke about
tourism and this there's a lot of
businesses though that are not affected
by terms of you know and so I would
suggest that we have the two elements to
this tourism and non tourism businesses
and we go we basically put a stake in
the ground and say we're going to look
reviewing and scrutinizing the business
side of what the council can do and is
doing and is proposing to do and we we
we cut all that up into tourism and on
tourism businesses but that's just
putting it out there to try and move
things forward I thought thank you for
that thank you yeah yeah sorry I thought
that sounds like a plan ish all right
let's go through this it's getting a bit
of a feel now it would feel everybody
seems to be on the same same page as you
were and okay any more thoughts
sorry just before while we've got Jill
on line with us because I'm I know it's
you new to the job
Jill and everything but is there
anything you think that that really we
could Garrett I'm happy with what makes
just said you know Tory diamond on
tourism and recovery nothing there they
are different and I think we need two
different things but for the for both
but I just wondered while you're on just
a vlog to become has any other ideas
you've got happened at the moment if
they graciously such a block wide and
all-encompassing things I think taking
tourism is one chunk is the right thing
to do I think as as you may be the
growth strategy when it serves as comes
out it might be that you want to then
focus on a part of the action that then
comes out the growth strategy to add
some value in so I would kind of leave
that open because you might then look at
that and go and decide yourselves that
actually we'd like to look at these part
of it alright thank you yeah I agree
that
okay right
thank you agree on that I think there's
some direction they're good on to item
six then draft word program soon can I
bring in Sylvania could I bring you in
on regards the year the draft word
program thank you you've seen the draft
that I sent out with the agenda pack and
that's on you start 410 and there's no
thinking there that you can you know you
can leave it out if you don't want in
there but it was just that you know
putting something down and what you've
been looking that in the past all you
said you might like to look at so really
it's just a discussion around the sort
of things you like would like to see on
the program and of course you know as
you've already mentioned the grocery is
going to be you know a large part of
that and just coming back to the point
that I think Jill dismayed and you know
there's nothing to stop you doing the
review on something and then doing the
quick little piece of work now something
that comes out and what you see in the
global strategy so you know it's not
either one or the other probably do golf
pieces were provided in our you know the
first one is interesting index with you
and but of course it could also form
just a one-off I to Missoula on and I'll
just mention for completeness some
outstanding work we had and you may
decide that you don't wish to pursue
this any further but just to close the
loop if you remember you did quite a lot
of work around the previous scrutiny on
business units industrial services
centers industrial units and we got to
the stage where the previous review the
polled had went cabinet but at that time
a number questions came in from members
of the committee and you felt that you
really needed more time to have looked
at that
so cabinet deferred that included
Baptist crucially for you to consider
you didn't burn up so and if you
remember we're going to have a number of
offices in from you know the director
the business center manager all in the
moon together the finance manager just
to talk about issues you'd have so I'm
mentioning that just in case she wished
to keep that on the work program or
whether yeah I think given the
circumstances that needs to just be put
to bed and forgotten about so that's one
question chair but you did ask for some
performance indicators yes yeah sorry
sorry just a butch anonymous on that sir
how does everybody feels because I
should know how do we feel about that
previous review these are the year
before last I said anybody got a strong
feels feelings on it that we need to be
going back to it or or is it something
we don't give up on any feelings anybody
at all Susie Susie it's impossible to
give us a summary of the things that
were we were having to review because I
was very involved in that
I've just so pushed it to one side
because I assumed it'd been dealt with
so I don't know what the magnitude of
the issues were I mean I don't like
doing a piece of work and it being
ignore yeah yeah again we say innocent
oh my my my thinking is and it's not to
make the word not know viable or not
it's not important enough but its story
in the past soon to women how are we
with with with issues so okay and we
don't have to summarize them now because
there was quite an extensive and
backwards and forth the questions as
well as the original report if it helps
the committee I can send out those
questions which I compiled into a
summary summary to see the
that you've got whether they satisfied
what you're looking for because that was
at the end of the year and obviously it
didn't get taken forward and also a copy
of the original report and its
recommendations and then perhaps you can
have a look at that outside of this
meeting individually and then come back
through the chairs to whether you think
Bonita - gone that I have the goal
without love is another system but it
was quite involved some of the questions
you asked
council Babaji
gotcha you know I was uh I was going to
say I think it's been done to death a
little bit and I know it's not a perfect
thing the the business centers and the
business units and possibly could be
managed better or whatever and Raich a
still but it has been a constant thing
for a long time when we're in control
we're constantly looking at that and I
think I've gone on what you say so let's
let's go back never look what was done
and I know I can understand why we're
doing again after the election but I
don't know again how much swelling we're
gonna add by keep going off of that
thanks Nigel a counselor finale John yes
hi Anthony Susie yay we did look at that
report and we would put it to one side
because it's thought things had moved on
a little bit but within the report there
was some sensible recommendations and I
think as a committee we should just go
through that again and see what we think
is appropriate to take you forward to
close it off I don't think it's right
that somebody should spend a year or
whatever looking at that through just to
be sidelined I think there's some
interesting things in there I think if
we look at it and endorse it or amend it
and then we can put it to bed after that
I'm not aware that okay thank you John
yeah I'm with you told her I'm not
trying to dismiss the thing of one tribe
do is move forward with it really rather
than just hanging around
and okay so I'll bring it back in there
you will ruin disgusting draft word
program work me
you
so are you soon
you again Oh your bike thank you yes I
mean I just switched itself ah yeah I
don't know why yes I'll send that those
documents out to you so you can have
another block and you'll also remember
that you're you did ask for some
performance indicators to be considered
other than the ones that you are seeing
in the performance reports in relation
to that and those have been produced
that so I'll send that report out as
well to you in terms of the mass of the
work program the only other item that
currently is on the draft one is the
partnership activities in support of
growth now that stays on or goes off
each other they come into the first
chair but that is where the partnership
team come and explain all the things
that they're doing supportive worlds and
then strangely enough on the April
meeting the previous school can be
walked tourism growth which was done a
couple years I was being monitored for a
while that was due to come back in the
into the committee for you to look at
what progress has been made
obviously is that something you decide
to pursue here other than that chair the
because you know and dissipated that you
the things that you thought were more
pressing matter moment right okay thank
you soon right that case we move on to
item number seven list of key decisions
well I think there are a list of key
decisions other
soon to them soon cranky chair so yes
it's been retitled for mana now can you
hear me you can just broke up a little
bit here just you say that again can you
hear me chair yes can hear you yeah yes
yeah it's been renamed yeah it's been
renamed chariot before executive
decisions and so I should know as you
know chair this is what every meeting
just so the committee can be aware of
the key decisions that have gone through
the authority and if there's anything on
there that's within you committees we
bit the yeah she want to ask for further
information no right
again soon
that wasn't forward you're on you're on
again sorry I cheese knife slice yeah I
think humans having a few technical
issues yeah I think just and whether
she's got any more to add to that item I
don't know you there soup so you like to
have gone wrong okay um well we really
need I need you to move on really soon
with this because next arts would be
item 8 additional urgent items I have no
digital version urgent items for today's
meeting Nigel sorry I was just just on
about the executive decisions they I've
just looked at that and I'm not quite
sure it's medium tell financial plans
and stuff like lamb sales I'm not quite
sure if they in re meeting up that's all
I want our you know what I mean it's got
four committees their body committees
probably look at the medium care
financial plan and that sort of still
for Anna it's it's so hard to make what
what is this committee looking at
there's both land sales we could look at
that but I'm not that mother to be
honest I think with all the priorities
you know it's gone these are most
immense Tom started my list either
really a council Welton welcome yeah
just on what Nigel Barker was so there's
woman aspect in sales that would come
with it with our remit and it's the
extent you would look at doing land
purchases using the obviously the
opportunity to perhaps buy land during a
period of time where they may well be
distressed sellers with lower prices it
has been discussed informally that would
be one number-one topic
right thanks Richard thank you for that
are you Mike sue I'm just trying you out
are you there yeah yes I can hear you
sue welcome by actually Thank You Chad
mama I was just wishing yourself off
without me betting any buttons yes well
this government really is about just
alerting making things that are going
off so you don't necessary have to do
anything with it it's just so that you
can look at it and see whether these
things that are in your room it just has
an interest in terms of the Lancer
health question that's a standing item
on the list and if there are land spells
going on then you see there's more
detail that's put in there to alert the
committee is something that might fall
within their lunette right I only know
that chair because the committees ask
the question before you know what you
know what is that sells about
okay thank you sir thank you Ray
additional urgent items I have no
additional urgent items today's meeting
are there any soon anything urgent
happen Anja no no no all right we're
moving on we Quicken
what we're doing in virtually doesn't it
because sometimes we can get one corrals
like this aurilla an hour in vain
tonight's meeting chair can I come in
there yes please sir thank you
yes just to inform the committee chair
and the next meeting was due to be held
on the 6th of July but circumstances
beyond our control with not holding that
meeting and I know unique and say sort
of thing further not if your bridge and
can I just say that if you do need to
hold that sex
meet in Council
yes we were so close they're so so
closely information it's just begun I
think what you're trying to say is that
God just arrived he says the what was
the right item just arrived rapid yeah
yeah I'm old enough to remember that and
so yes I think everything just the gist
of what you were trying to say there
soon we're at the end of our meeting
[Music]
else to actually say there I mean oh
yeah I mean Abby we're not having a
meeting on the seat so when oh everyone
the six Oh Mifflin can I just bring you
in sorry John I'll be you know yeah I'm
just she was saying is that the next
meeting of the committee that scheduled
in the meeting scheduled for I believe
it was the 6th of July unfortunately can
go ahead if members wish to have another
meeting prior to the meeting after that
we can try to organize one if not it
would take place in September I believe
no sorry I'm looking at the wrong table
here next week we take place on the 7th
of September we can't wait till
September for our next meeting
I really appreciate these meetings been
moved to Monday I can't tell you how
beneficial that is to me but I really
don't wait till September comment right
well what we'll we'll come up with
something then Nicola still chair you
are able to hold your meeting on the day
that you wish to you unfortunate you
wouldn't be able to hold it at the time
that you have the reason for that being
is that we obviously would go using the
live streaming software and we have
another meeting that's live streaming at
the same time so we won't be able to do
two at the same time so if you wish to
change the time of your meeting on that
day that's possible
or of course for the legislation the new
pony by recycling distribution allows us
to counsel and organize meetings as see
is seen fit by the authority so you're
able to spot in another meeting at a
date convenient yourselves right okay
we'll come back to that in a moment
thank you John sorry can't bring you in
believe yeah yeah just yeah I picked up
on the meeting they say no we know and
wait till September but I'm happy to
show you in a different time on the
Monday on this on the 6th of July just
for confirmation
have we agreed that Jill will come to
the next meeting and present a growth
strategy for us number one
I'm following that endorsing what Nick
said earlier we should really identify a
serious scrutiny topic based on what the
growth strategy is and then we'll have
something to look at in a bit more
detail going forward so can you just
confirm that Jill will be doing that
right Jill I know you're still there
Jill would you well we're going to
discuss and come up with a time probably
which we will be the sixth that's a
difference I'm during the day would you
be willing to come in with us
Jill yes no can you hear me yeah happy
to and I can't say it will be completed
growth strategy because it's a work in
progress now I'm here but I can give you
where we are now for your news and ideas
that's alright you know that John yes
but like right sue thank you you'll soon
I just see you've caught with it I can
see now which is even better and yet we
all we all agree that set to embrace is
all on one one way away and personally
any time of the day is fine by me but
for a meeting
I don't know how everybody else feels
could we perhaps rearrange some before
for the 6th of July but maybe earlier
so sweet yes ever since we quite keen on
that us grain Nikki you you don't say
something yes of course it was just you
know of course that Dana Stanton who
whose Clark for the meeting it would be
more than happy to contact all members
and find a convenient time and a great
outside visiting that's true thank you
for that Thank You Damon and Lee
yes coming up disturb agree of time now
while we're already ten o'clock and I'm
and if we can accommodate ten o'clock
then of course we'll hold the meeting
it's obviously it's more than just the
members here we have to make sure that
we can actually facilitate that for you
so we all investigate ten o'clock and
confirm to you that that's going to be
working for you thank you that's great
thanks
right no more questions no more comments
from anybody right in that case I thank
you very much for today's attendance we
are doing like this it's not like face
to face is he thanks very controversial
and I like to declare today's meeting
closed
I now see you both talk on the 6th of
July all right thank you today saying
yeah
you